you've done this job before
so there and I might grab his wrist so
don't get confused with that I'm just
putting my hand you see that
and then my thumbs open because when I
go to shomenuchi like this
that is resting on now
and I'm going to bring my hand up and
like I'm going to do so many okay so can
you do that it's just resting
don't push me it's just rest and then
bringing hand up by Kennedy shoulders
okay so as he goes up and back towards
him
that's the Guinean did you get it so he
goes up I will do a young hand but if I
push now
then I'm going too far into you because
when I now when I push past that that's
a young Anyang clutch so this is another
yin and Yan harmonization so he goes I
am NOT shoving him up there I just
matched with him as white as he is my
hand is there there was a gap did you
see that
so he goes out that's a graph you see
that that's two yet I'm tuyen to his
game so I fill the space fill the space
and when I fill the space I don't
overflow the space
so that will help answer your question
then we do the other side so I just fill
the space and this side fill the space
mmm show the space okay let's try this
okay some things to look for is he comes
he comes up to the final spot and I'm
here you see where I am okay so when he
comes up to the final spot that's it's
how I got there so did you see that one
tell you guys if you know I I filled the
space underneath it is more that he is
putting his arm where my hand needed to
be
you see that difference so here is I'm
going I'm getting there
here I just fit perfectly
he's putting his hand
so this is an exaggeration of this but
this too is wrong you see that keep
going keep going
that's all that's me trying to get there
okay
by just harmonizing with his energy even
if he doesn't mess me up because I
shouldn't be pushing on his ski it's
just facing it he ends up there you see
that okay so with that in mind he
doesn't he's going to do it again
and I've raised the other hand
so I'm not going like this the two heads
fit the two heads fit in there boom so
right where this hand gets its grip this
hand finishes boom it's Hansel too much
he goes
okay question alright for some reference
sake and this is gonna be to you
shomenuchi is usually or commonly
addressed by two things so you have the
people who just do young on y'all so he
does shomenuchi and they catch it here
and oh that was a class he was coming
down oh it doesn't matter if I go like
this and do this stuff it's a class
llaman y'all then other people go to
know that is advice so they will just
stick that hand out it never comes them
know you guys do what I did I know it's
retired handout never comes down well
you didn't have a class but I didn't
have a conflict to resolve either okay
and the other one is no no no that is
like he said that's just lame then the
other people go I do the strike and then
he blocks and then I usually yeah but
again I don't have a conflict to see
that so we're doing we're answering your
question how do I do the in young
reconciliation we're now moved from I on
me to show minutiae this is the
ballistic equivalent of the fixated on
me okay so he comes up right
I'm just filming the in space okay this
time he's going to come up and on this
foot okay again up and I'm going to come
up and all
the same way if I if he goes up and I
come up early
you're gonna be pushing on that so we've
gone from keema soupy at the hands at
the hand to at the hands now to the body
and what you want is to start getting
this feeling this feeling this he would
see not this Q this Q
okay let's go so we already have some
deviation but the concepts remain the
same so first thing is we're not doing
EQ yet we're drilling our way to there
okay so we started here we start here
and not here for katuk Sidoti because
this is not where the conflict happens
in completa 30 I mean in shomenuchi so I
can't hit him striking is has to start
earlier because it's moving faster but
actually happens closer because that's
where the target is happening so don't
start changing it then the second thing
is just as he goes up and I follow it if
that's as high as his elbow goes that's
where my hand stops you were told don't
go young on y'all well what's wrong with
this picture go up on your foot I win
your mind young so in this drill what
I'm trying to do is keep my CV that
means I'm not I've matched him so where
he steps that's where I step that is
where I step now this is also a problem
this this is because you're going yan
yan but he is abnormally long that's not
what we're doing either so feel where
you can step and just maintain this zero
pressure by the side he goes
okay go inside pretty much so now we'll
go into the army and okay and we're
going to do this same drill so we're
hungry but a very unusual River and
again not this musubi this musubi and
not this musubi his flesh of my flesh
but this musubi his his breath his
spirit
okay let's go okay if I am doing Kokomo
I have his head making that loop so it
can go back if I am doing maybe not get
it it's not here my gosh what that loose
does that figure eight on there it is it
allows his legs to become lighter and
his legs keep going through okay so
rather than push his elbow what I want
to do is let his legs come through okay
so we're gonna have to gain this at the
beginning okay so when you step you're
going to drive your body
we'll go slow for you so he comes up
woulld and this Duke that's what I want
as his legs come through that elbow gets
lighter because his mouth gets
disconnected you see that and it becomes
good but if not quite me pushing him I
Lord let him through so he goes up boom
and again we're just going to stretch
each other right now
[Music]
okay it would be wrong like this
there's no loose okay so it's just like
everything the loop happens inside
there's okay so this is the clicker
question was on the Union reconciliation
but don't think that the test of offie
isn't part of it you can't just do
whatever so this shape is here you see
that this this shape is officially this
shape is
is the same shape he's doing so which
direction are not hands going at the end
of this and actually coming this way so
not this way that's gonna push you into
Yong so he goes up right you're over
here this is your overextended so match
his body pull and instead do how to cook
you Nagas home augment feeling his legs
get life and come through that's what
you want not
at this level be patient
[Music]
okay try so he goes again hope then the
sube is do it do it
hope the musubi is in here boom boom
this is the Mississippi's not to name
the city boom see connection is here
through gun start coming through harder
don't break again so that's what what
happened as if you can if you're not
going to expect to fall because you are
going forward and it something really
strong and then you go unconscious at
the bottom but you have a second
convention going to offer okay
do you understand yes okay so this to me
is not on behalf it's still raining here
okay okay so now you get your your dog
and pony show
now you start coming in like this it's
supposed to come down yeah I believe the
down energy that's what makes you think
like okay so don't come in like that
you're not gonna like agency I would
feel you're all here so I'm gonna need
you me till I hit your spine you
understand okay so your your your attack
was up on the top do it right here boom
pop okay
that's his sole intention a full but as
he doesn't experience the fall he has to
maintain consciousness and give that
second contention point so make sure you
put me down he goes
then here no okay okay I'm going to ask
you a question see how oh you understand
so guys how come I can't do this why
can't I hold this
what
now just banks anomaly you could just
touch that ballistic strength
[Music]
how come in my mind standing where I was
fighting why can't I hold the wrist it
use a wrist elbow fall
doesn't light in the legs doesn't allow
it does it does you can do it which
means what
nope
no because I would require you to in
order to get it when decided that
require you to come
okay or I can do what
wait for it to come down and if I wait
for it to come down then what do I have
a class see that so if I if I go catch
it here I can treat you better if we
meet in the middle then I can do it do
you see and then I can get but that was
a class which means I got to be strong
enough to take that okay
so learn not to go to the wrist we have
the same control point the eye on me
is the elbow the elbow and the center so
we're now standing that foots back he
comes in and I'm looking for this and
not looking for this
did you come down I'm not looking
hey let's try just like the last video
about Hancock - we're gonna keep
differently okay so here's where you're
starting to even into any website okay
let's do a strike do this right
whoa okay strikes hard as you can it's
too much space you know we're gonna
start doing this in here okay so he goes
up and I'm close that's too far
[Music]
remember that musubi is already all
right all right now it feels like I'm
moving before he moves and it might work
to you at this speed like I'm moving for
you but I'm slowing down
he's moving quite a bit before I
actually move what I'm not doing is this
oh yeah okay if you see the hand you're
too late
so you feel the energy and remember just
like you taught sex the elbows legs
elbows back
[Music]
okay because I'm holding harmonizing the
image on I don't have to grab anything I
don't have to ground I just say it
we're glued together wool or glue